in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Michael
and Paige are with us hey guys how are
you hey how are you better than I
deserve welcome welcome good to have you
guys
thank them where do you live we are in
Charlotte North Carolina cool and how
much dad have you paid off thirty two
thousand six hundred and eighteen and
one penny very cool very cool and how
long did that take you
I took us about 13 months wow you did it
fast and the range of your income during
that time about 84,000 got a couple
raises couple bonuses up to 128 way to
go what do you all do for a living I'm a
data consultant for a health care
company okay and I am an account
management for a procurement services
organization very cool good for you guys
very well done so what kind of debt was
the thirty three thousand oh well
Michael says he married into it loans so
that was part of it yeah we had two cars
and a whole lot of student debt okay all
right so what happened thirteen months
ago how long have you been married
coming up on three years I think right
in June so you know I've been a fan for
a long time I mentor at work give me
your audiobook bill layman shout out and
about four five years about I've been
listening to you but uh we got married
we took financial piece together she
still wasn't on board wasn't on board
went on board and finally you know about
16 months ago I guess now she said I've
had it whatever you say let's do it and
that's really when we started our debt
free journey what caused that page um I
just trusted in him I finally was just
like let's just do it I got frustrated
I'm a spender I like to shop and it just
took a while it did but now I just know
that he's leading our family and it's
such a blessing so so blessed well but I
mean you got frustrated that you weren't
getting traction it sounds like is that
right or not are you just yeah yes
you were a curse word for a long time in
our household before again okay so you
kind of just got he just badgered you
into it huh yeah it's just he listened
to your show every day man just talk
about Dave Ramsey Dave Ramsey and I was
like let's just do it you know if I if I
get out of that well you never mentioned
Dave Ramsey and here we are there you go
very good well good so you sat down at
that point you said okay I surrender the
match ring we're gonna try this and you
guys sat down to do a budget or what
happened yeah just sat down and did a
budget actually Michael led FPU he
facilitated the class at a local church
and I think at that point you know when
I saw how importing it porn and it was
to him I just realized that it's time
it's time to do it so the way you said
that it sounds like you did not go
through it I I did she went through it
the first time the first time I think it
took me actually leading the class and
her kind of being there to a support
system oh that really helped her kind of
all right if we're gonna lead this thing
then we yeah yeah one thing Paige
doesn't do is hypocrite yeah yeah I'm
not gonna stand here and act like I'm
doing something I'm not okay okay so we
sat down did the budget laid it all out
and 13 months later plowed through
$33,000 what was the last debt you all
paid off student loans yeah and how did
that feel Paige great
we actually woke up one morning got
ready for work and went downstairs and
did it just hit the button and it was
done I expected you know confetti to go
everywhere and and where there was work
yeah it didn't happen but you know and
Wyatt we went to work that day and you
know we're just texting each other and
just man you just felt that
accomplishment and then actually cool
story when I got home that day she had
the place decorated oh and she bought a
banner on Etsy that said we're debt-free
and so we had our own little celebration
there so it was a really cool venue yeah
well that's perfect very cool good for
you that's that's good thanks
okay so now you're leading the class and
what do you tell people that the key
what worked for you all to get you out
of that you know I think you can't do
this alone I think that was the biggest
thing early on I was so intense I was
probably pushing it a bit too hard
sounds like yeah just this touch and you
know really when she threw her hands up
and said all right we're gonna do this
as a couple you know this is you know
marriage is is this is what it's about
so we're gonna we're gonna do it
together we're gonna sit down and do our
monthly budget meetings there's a couple
months where I forgot to do the budget
meeting and and she called me on it you
know just team work page what do you
tell people the key is to you're all
success I would just say the same thing
it's so important to be on the same page
and if you're not there's just that
constant tension I saw it before when I
wasn't on the same page you know the
money fights they're just not fun and
even moving forward after being out of
debt we're just gonna continue to be on
the same page about things we're gonna
continue to set a budget and just grow
together and have something have some
fun so so what advice would you have do
a husband that's listening or a wife
that's listening given your old track
record yeah you know maybe I got there
maybe there's a reluctant spouse in a
relationship out there listening right
yeah you know I think it's it's a little
foreign to people you know especially
you know we have friends out there that
aren't on the same page and don't share
their money and you know that's not what
the Bible says and it's it's just so
important just to be on the same page
and agree and you know this plan works
it really does I mean if you follow this
thing I mean one of the hardest things
for me was cutting off the 401k you know
when I finally did that it was like all
right you got to do it now so if you
follow the steps and you follow the baby
steps it's a guaranteed plan it's gonna
work there might be some speed bumps but
you know see it through so tell the
husbands that are badgering their wives
what they ought to do different than
maybe Michael did page he got you there
but it doesn't sound like it was a
pleasant experience yeah I mean just be
patient with the spouse who's not on
board
you know don't come home every day
talking about it
it's okay to but just be patient have
patience they'll get there but something
happened in the process not in the
badgering I'm all kidding aside that one
day you looked up and you said all right
I'm gonna go with my man on this yeah
and or the guy looks up and says I'm
gonna go with my wife on this yeah and
and I trust them yeah there's something
that happens there in the relationship
that's very very important
yeah our marriage grew a lot in the past
13 months very cool I'm very proud of
you guys you're rocking real people and
you really did this you really paid off
$33,000 in really 13 months really
making 84 to 128 count it down let's
hear a free screen yes all right three
two one
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind